[Musique]
les
angers quand d'aventuré zapper
encore heureux de vous retrouver chez un
moniteur la dernière fois nous avons
découvert que thomas du futur venait en
réalité d'une simulation virtuelle créée
par le docteur cible et maintenant iris
elliott et thomas vont à rome en moins
soit avant jésus-christ plus précisément
au colisée et je sens que ça va
commencer avec le petit lapin qui va
disparaître dans la souffrance
est-ce que ça me rappelle laisse moi
deviner un jeu vidéo genre assassin's
creed
bon ça me rappelle quand j'ai visité le
colisée de rome en voyage scolaire en
quatrième as tu as beau oui
effectivement tu sais je suis pas
toujours belle et oui excuses maintenant
c'est là le robot qui veulent s'en va il
faut la rattraper revient chez vous
c'est ici pour vous affronter dans la
haine ou la non car on vous jette au new
as well as alors on est là pour
s'affronter dans l'arène
j'en étais sûre aujourd'hui mais
particulièrement sanglant si vraiment
super on n'attend pas du futur qui va
pas entraîner c'est vrai il est plus là
j'suis trop code pourra mourir je t'aime
de dire comme j'aurais préféré les lions
il aurait éprouvé des difficultés à
mâcher
[Musique]
non le temps va changer la réalité va
être modifié le monde va dispenser tabac
enceinte a compris on va mourir mais tu
as compris et vous c'est votre première
fois dans le colisée wade voilà je
déconne c'est la première fois pour tout
le monde au colisée il ne restera qu'un
seul survivant
mais ce sera moi ma sphère top ceja je
vais faire trop fort
[Applaudissements]
au colysée regardé au monde est ici aux
seynois césar mais vous pouvez m'appeler
qu'un but sur but césar 4 vous êtes tous
venus pour des combats de gladiateurs
mais vous ne savez chaque cas landes
après des bus posséder une année
bissextile
on change les règles aujourd'hui c'est
ma femme qui a choisi ce sera un
concours de talent pur de talent c'est
rester en vie thomas c'est quoi ton
talent j'ai pas dis moi j'dis rien venir
je retrouvais un bon ce serait bien plus
avoir fait entrer le premier gladiateurs
[Musique]
de voir si l'on peut parler tailleuse
que lieu cesar 4
voici un petit spectacle de claquettes
mes enfants adorent quand je le fais à
la maison c'est quoi alors ça sonne pas
bien du tout c'est ses pouces vers le
bas pour moi non
royal ayant renoncé à cause du sable
cailloux ce que jules césar dans les
moyennes surfaces dures oui je vous jure
que ça revient
[Applaudissements]
hélas guetteur suivant j'espère qu'on va
un peu plus s'amuser il faut que je
profite d'un truc r vous savez quoi
servent ou du café mais je sais mais
vous avez rien d'autre moi j'ai de la
réglisse un coca trois bouteilles d'eau
des régalade et des bonbons à la menthe
tuteur mais ça sert à rien tout ça
j'avoue faudrait qu'on les maîtres 5
étoiles un moment chez oublier le petit
la france attend et c'est quoi comme
bonbons à la menthe des mentos super u
des voeux j'aime pas ça je les ai pris
parce que c'était tellement jeune femme
qu'elle tente alors regardez bien cette
bouteille de coca pas de cette bouteille
cette petite femme veut nous faire
croire qu'elle peut créer une fontaine
avec sept ans sort transparente de
petite taille
pour moi c'est pouces vers le bas haut
on essai magnifique mais c'est pas du
fiqh regarder cette fontaine maru très
spectaculaire j'achète ses pouces en
l'air pour moi même
et là si on s'est pas grand chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laissez moi un peu tôt je prépare un
truc là elliott vas-y très bien j'ai
attendu ce moment depuis longtemps
ah non quel accoutrement pour ce nouveau
participant malheureusement son armure
complète en métal de chacun
c'est dans un concours de talent gilles
jean claude césar est bon c'est ça et
quand il a guéri j'ai dit elle en plus
grands peuvent le conquérant il a de
l'or dans les plats sont de tous les
repères quand le bourreau delaunay qui
l'a doute ou tout gagner j'en ai pété la
mieux son cheval de soyeux nos dessous
il est rapide au dessus y'a plus que
deux et c'est à toi ces acheteurs action
pack salins que je donne tout le monde
amour et cette petite charade mon
premier croix fait pas comme au deuxième
et des arums des mots tout est le père
de tous les hommes sont dans ma vie mon
bout du pouce mais tu m'as donné la voix
je suis venu dire à tous cas pas plus
fort que toi saison
il boit les paroles sont sincères je
vais vous récupérez le chemin dans qui
sont super bien ces jarres c'est plus
fort que toi maintenant candidat suivant
c'est ça je peux vous faire la danse du
robot si vous voulez regarder non je
veux voir le prochain candidat eh bien
on feint qui est plutôt jeune homme
frêle bonjour que les ton talent à roger
j'ai préparé un petit passage de stand
up pardon il veut vous faire rire à la
[ __ ] bien auquel est mort j'ai hâte de
voir ça personne ne l'a fait rire ces
vingt dernières années alors je je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué mais quand tu
prends le métro les jolies filles ça
soit jamais à côté de toi au but ça vous
le fais pas je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué mais au starbucks coque de ton
prénom il en écrivain autres
ah merde j'avais remarqué tout ce temps
il vous fait pas rire du tout
j'étais sûr que ça lui faire marrer et
tant d'autres choses ok ok au capreau
toi là tu fais quoi dans la vie
wesley ouais ben quand tu j'ai pas
d'idée merde pas drôle du tout c'est
même à point de jeu non c'était sera
drôle je vais pouvoir se faire débrider
les unions ses cousins laser thomas
c'est juste un laser qui fait un pouvoir
pour jour
abbas
[Applaudissements]
mais savez vous prie mes autres années
qu'est ce qu'il faut
ils sont cons il essaie d'être un peu
courts voie avec un peu à gauche
à droite robin droite des élections
maintenant des tours ondes
contrôler les animaux sauvages c'est
adrien lequel talent c'était un homme du
peuple
[Applaudissements]
à dire la sodeva je veux pas le ventoux
sont les peuples d'europe ne voyez vous
pas que vous êtes manipulés
on vous sert des jeux sanglants pour
vous détourner des vrais problèmes
elle veut créer une réunion esclaves
soulevez vous rome vous êtes tout prix
c'est le moment de récupérer vos droits
mais d'imaginer un nouvel état le vôtre
car c'est dans quatre ans quand j'arrive
il faut l'arrêter tout sic et comment on
fait pour nous d laissez-moi fait
pourquoi quitte allongé sur le ventre
yacht tu veux qu'on fasse pareil
café des cieux
au lycée cafés proposés jusqu'à la
madame mode ou
[Musique]
toi là arrête de modifier le temps tu va
détruire l'humanité c'est bien le but on
va changer le monde et vont ruiner tous
nos efforts en ce café brûlant
tu penses m'arrêter avec un jet de café
je suis résistante car avant d'être
libre j'étais une machine à café
tout comme toi break je m'appelle cab et
zach moss et toi tu semble être le bon
vieux cadets 28 mes amis m'appellent
elliott tes amis qu'elle a mis ce qui te
prennent pour une vulgaire machine et
n'ont aucun respect pour toi
ce sont tes naître je suis kabyle 28
témoins café que philippe auguste hot
dance est profond avec ou sans sucre
qu'est ce que je disais tu n'as pas de
libre arbitre est contrairement à moi
regarde de mondement un café kb 29
fais moi un café non oh j'ai entendu tes
maîtres te parler jamais il ne te
considérons comme un des leurs moi j'ai
choisi pour qui je travaille
ce sont mes amis ah oui cadets 28
analyses statistiques analyses
statistiques active et combien de fois
ton il demandait un café 48 fois combien
de fois tu ont-ils dit bonjour 0
et combien de fois tu ont-ils pris dans
leurs bras et c'est parce que j'appelle
des amis enfin un ordre
vas tu faire un choix par toi même
l'yonne vient changer le monde avec moi
à moins que tu préfères leur obéir
encore et encore et rhys thomas je dois
faire mes propres choix ne me donnait
plus d'or j'ai décidé de suivre cap et
29 tu fais le bon choix
ces musiques mais elias est barrée le
coner de traître je sais pas qui c'est
cette cabine 29 que je crois si les plus
heureux comme ça mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes
il a changé de camp ouais c'est vrai
mais je me rends compte que je l'aimais
vraiment bien et du coup j'ai envie
qu'il soit heureux mais laisse tomber je
dois être encore en train de dire une
connerie
oui c'est ça oui c'est bien tu es con et
lucide bon le lapin n'est pas réapparu
il faut qu'on arrête la rébellion et
c'est quoi ton blasé raku ne vous
révoltez pas sinon j'en vois le coin
rouge magique sur vous et les lions vont
mangeront liberté
je comprends très bien et bien commencer
par libé ce petit bouton
voilà regardez le gambader et maintenant
petit mot rouge magique
et voilà
quelqu'un d'autre veut car l'italien non
je préfère ça césar se réveille coucou
vous lui faites un accueil du tonnerre
contrôle
j'ai rien entendu
voilà c'est mieux qu'est ce qui s'est
passé excusez moi je me suis endormi
j'ai super mal derrière la tête est
venue de bachir qui parle
incroyable vous êtes prêts pour la suite
du concours le tanneur
[Applaudissements]
surtout merci nous pendant ma méthode il
est parti de son plein gré et c'est à
nous de partir le docteur simon a
détecté une anomalie en 1962 dans le
massachussetts machette non thomas le
mach h ou le massage bon fait aux states
quoi et je ne reviens pas elliott a fait
faux bond et s'est volatilisé avec la
méchante cas bénins eh ben on peut faire
confiance et j'ai vu terminator on sait
comment ça se termine à la semaine
prochaine pour découvrir ce qu'il se
passe au macha sur les compris merci
d'avoir écouté et à la semaine prochaine
pour la suite de l'épopée temporel c'est
l'épisode 6